all right
so let's get started
um I hope you had an awesome lunch and
now you're ready to see some typescript
beside your c-sharp stuff and that stuff
you see all day so my name is Christian
I'm a senior full stack engineer and I'm
from Switzerland working in the industry
for over a decade now I've started with
Java around 12 years ago so I was always
in this in this type language field so I
didn't really touch JavaScript until
I've joined a team which also was doing
angular just a quick note of hand how
how many of you do typescript
nice nice nice cool and how many of you
do angular
okay yeah all for you so hopefully I can
show you some things you haven't seen by
using typescript because many of you and
me too often just use normal just simple
types and not really that crazy stuff
typescript has to offer so hopefully I
can show you something which you haven't
seen in a while
so before we start let's dive deep
together into typescript and let's see
this animation
it took me almost more time to do this
in PowerPoint and all the other stuff in
typescript I will show you today
but so appreciate it so okay let's get
started so
hopefully you can see this well in the
background I will make it a little bit
bigger and now
the what I'd like to show you is at the
top right here you can see like a small
agenda maybe it's a little bit too small
for the background but it's not really
that important and we can see what we'll
talk about and the important stuff about
this to do app here is it's completely
written in types so this is written by
I've created a small plugin which does
just check your typescript file and
search for a type called result
and just shows what's in this result
and there if you would compile this to
dos.ts file there would be no JavaScript
code it's just a type file basically but
it's interactive so if I change this for
example from a zero to a two
then as you can see now this changes to
burning symbol so this old on types and
so we'll get started with with map types
so that you can show you a little bit
about this so let's say we have an event
type here and let's say we have an ad
event and we have a remove event and now
let's say we want to have like user
actions with which are also typed so
let's say we have like a user actions
here and this is of type on event
so now you could for example say well I
have an on ad which is just a function
which does nothing in our case and on
remove which also does nothing in our
case now how can we make this on event
type well we can just say of course well
I have this type here on event and then
I just say well I have this on ad which
is a function which turns anything and
on remove which is a function and which
does basically anything we'd like now
the problem here is that events and all
events is not connected with each other
so if I for example add here A Move
string then everything still compiles
because we do not have the connection
between this on event and these events
but we would like to like get a compile
time error as soon as we change
something in the events so how can we do
this
we can use so-called mapped type so
first let's create a helper type let's
say we have an event Keys here and this
is key of events so this type contains
all the property Keys as available
strings
and so what we can now do is we remove
this these types here and we use a map
type and can say well our key has to be
in event keys so basically we are only
allowing this event Keys properties as
our own event keys so we then can say
again well we have just a function and
as you can see user user actions does no
longer compile
so we have to change this to be the same
and now even user actions doesn't
compile anymore because we need to add
this move function
now this is nice but the problem here is
that we still don't have this on and the
uppercased first letter of our of our ad
remove and move property so how can we
do this well we can map our key we can
say s and then use back ticks to use
template literals and say well I
prefixed this with on and then use like
you would do in JavaScript and you can
use like a template syntax and can say I
use key in here
and as you can see now you can now use
on add on remove and on move and this
now compiles again now we're almost
there but still it's not uppercased so
what we can do is we can use typescripts
and internal intrinsic functions and we
can use capitalize
and what this does is as you can see
this along compiles I now have to
uppercase this
and what this now does is
this is an intrinsic function from
typescript compiler so typescript
compiler says well we know what you want
to do we don't show how we do it but we
do it internally in our compiler so it's
just done you can also use uppercase or
lowercase and um there are some other
intrinsic functions you can just visit
the typescript website and play it and
playground with it so but the cool thing
now what we what we achieved is if I for
example now say well I will change an
event from move for example to line then
we would have to change this also to it
being online because otherwise it our
code will not compile and even if I for
example remove an element here then it
would get an exception at compile time I
know that you can not on runtime you
won't get an unexpected exception this
way
so this is just a little introduction to
map types because we will use them later
in the talk
so
now let's talk about template literals
and template riddles let's say we have
something which we do each day we want
to create like all possible positions on
a chessboard so what we could do we
could say well we have A1 and they have
A2 and so on but you had would have to
do this 64 times and this is quite a
boring task so let's type let typescript
do this for you so we can say we have a
chest letter type and this is either a
or
B some typing you have to do and c and
so on you get it and then you have your
chest number type here and this is
either one or two or three and so on and
now what we say is we say well we want
to create a port we use the spec ticks
for template literals then we can say
well I want the first element to be a
chest letter the second element to be
the chest number
and now
what typescript here does to it for us
it creates every possible combination of
these of these strings so from A1 to C3
and now you could do this of course you
can just add other things and then it
will create all the possible
permutations of it
so but how can we use this in a more
real life scenario so let's say we have
like
an rgbcs CSS type and let's say we have
like a wrong CSS and this is like RGB
one one for example and there is one
Element missing in there because you
need these three elements and then you
have a correct CSS
and this is RGB
one one one
now we say these both are of course
rgbcss type
now of course currently it is compiles
because it's just an alias for a string
now we can change this we can say well
we want this to be a template literal
and we can say well it's prefixed with
RGB and in there there has to be a
number
and another number
and the third one
and as you can see in our wrong CSS does
no long compile because we have stated
that we want this exact pattern in our
string so if I now add here of course
another element this now compiles but as
soon as for example an a here and it's
no longer a number typescript also
recognizes this and says oh well this is
not this is not a valid number so I
would have to change this for example to
string to make this compile again
so we can now combine these two things
and let's create like a margin padding
validator so let's say we have a gap
type here and this is either margin or
padding
and now we have our positions which is
either left or bottom or top
or
right
so now what we can say is we have our
Gap CSS which then we can take our more
our Gap type
error Gap type and
our
positions
and now of course this creates margin
left top right bottom and padding Left
Right top button now we can go further
we can say we have our size type here
this is either for example rem or M
or pixel and then we have our size CSS
and this is then a number prefix
number prefix
and a size type
and now what we can do with this is we
can combine these two things and can say
well let's create a marching padding
type here and we can use like map types
again we can say well in the key has to
be in
to be in gap CSS and the value is size
CSS and now if we create here our
Merchant object with Merchant padding
we now see that if we check for what we
have here in our Auto completion we have
margin bottom left right top and as
values only these valid types are
allowed so if I for example would use
one ram instant one ram then we I would
get an error if I change this back then
this works but here as we can see a
typescript is not completely satisfied
because we said well we want like an
object with all the possible margins and
paddings specified in there so to fix
this we add a question mark in here and
we tell typescript we only want to add
certain elements we want to decide
ourselves which elements we want to to
add
so this is about template literals so
let's talk about a type in typescript
which many of you maybe already have
seen but maybe not have used that much
it's the never type so let's say we have
in hello object here and it's called
hello NDC now of course what we could do
is we can say implicitly this hello is a
string now we can explicitly say this is
a string this works but if we change
this to never of course we can error
because string is not assignable to type
never well if we get such an error we as
typescript programs know what to do we
say as any and it's fixed but as you can
see something crazy happened it's not
fixed because you can't even assign any
to never you can't assign anything to
never which is not never itself so if I
would change this to never please don't
do this
then it would work but that's of course
the case so why is this helpful before
we go deeper into this type I have to do
quick sign over about conditional types
so what are conditional times let's say
we have a type Boolean or else
and we pass it in a generic type so
something we can which is which is
generic which can change during during
runtime so we can then say well in case
of T being a Boolean so if T is is the
type Boolean not exactly but it's like
it contains this then in this case we
say well we return the Boolean let's
otherwise just return a string now to
test this
we can just say Boolean or else and
let's just return
the Boolean in there and of course
there's no magic it will return Boolean
if I change this for example to number
then it will return a string because
it's not a Boolean so this can we can
use to use our never type
so let's say we have a function here
fail on empty string
and we pass it in an input
and we want it to fail if the input
length is not set
and we say input is empty now this of
course throws an error at runtime and I
also want to to emphasize that
we are using typescript but if we if we
compile this this all the types will go
away so for at runtime we don't have
these types so it's always if you for
example write a library and you think
maybe someone who uses JavaScript will
use my library always make sure that you
also do some runtime checks on the
important parts of your of your library
to make it easier for the user to or for
the programmer to use your library so
that's why it's we will throw an error
at runtime but the sad part here is fail
an empty string of course
takes this empty string and doesn't yell
at me at compile time even if I clearly
State I don't want this empty string so
how can we fix this we can use these
conditional types with never we can say
we create the type no empty string we
pass it in a t and say well this has to
be some kind of string we don't care
what string but it has to be a string
and then we say well if T extends an
empty string so if T is an empty string
and has nothing in it
in this case return never
wise return t and now of course nothing
has changed because we haven't used this
in our failed on empty string so let's
use this let's put this in here say this
is a string here and instead of a string
as the input it's now a no empty string
with this t
and now something interesting happened
you maybe already have seen it and this
code on line 11 doesn't compile anymore
because what it tells you is you can't
assign string to never so what did we
really do here we put in here this empty
string this is just this t
and because T here is an empty string it
returns never so what we are basically
trying to do here is trying to have this
input here of type never and try to
assign an empty string to it and this is
of course not allowed so this way you
can create like types which do not allow
even primitive types to be in a certain
pattern
so this is just a little simple
introduction how you can use this never
type to like narrow down
your your types which kind of strings
you want to allow in it so but let's go
further and a little bit more in a real
life scenario we say we have locations
and let's say we have suric and we have
Oslo
so let's say we have a function get
country for locations and we have our
location which we put in here and we
return a string now we want for each of
our location the corresponding country
now let's use a switch statement you
could also use if else this works fine
too and we can then use location here
and we can say well in case of cyric
we return
Switzerland
So currently now typescript says well
you have only covered this one branch
but there is this Oslo possibility and
for this you would just return undefined
because the switch case does not cover
this this Oslo case so of course we will
fix this we will say Oslo is in here and
we turn nor way
and now typescript is satisfied so but
the problem is again we don't have to
runtime safety so if I say get country
for locations and I pass in anything as
any
because that's basically what you do if
you work only with JavaScript everything
is any because the types will get
stripped away so the problem is you can
pass in anything you'd like so to have
the runtime safety what you do is you
say well I have a default clause and you
say Throw new error
and you say well the location is not
known
but now something now we have fixed this
runtime problem but the problem now is
well if I add
here let's say London
now if I call this with London I don't
get in I don't get the thing I'd like
because I've forgotten to add this in my
switch case and it will throw an error
at runtime but I don't want this I want
that at compile time typescript tells me
hey you have forgotten to add this here
I want to type script to help me as much
as possible so how can we fix this
how we count how can we have both well
we can say we add a new variable here
and can call it whatever we want I call
this exhaustive and then the important
part we assign never the never type to
it and then we try to assign location to
it and now we get an error why because
typescript knows well you will if this
is London case is not covered in the
switch in this switch case and it will
go into the default and then you will
try to assign London to never which is
not allowed but the cool thing now is as
soon as I now say okay I have to add
London here
then this error goes away so this way
you have to compile time and the runtime
safety because you have to cover all the
branches otherwise typescripts the the
typescript code will not compile at all
so this is how you can use the never
type like to also have like this
exhaustive switches without having to
lose the runtime the runtime checks and
still have the compile time checks for
it
lender says well
you are never you are never using it
you're never using it so well you maybe
would have to go like this and say Yes
Lind I don't care
care or something like this
but I don't really know yeah but I think
you what you could also do is wrap this
in a function to reuse it but I think we
can live with this
I I don't see this lender errors anymore
there or just the way if it's not red on
the line I don't see it so okay
um let's now go to a keyword to the
infer keyword
so what can the infer keyword do for us
let's say we have a really complex
function I don't try to explain what it
does because it's
I don't even know what it does so but
the important part here is that we have
a function which we can work with so and
because this is such a complex function
I'd like to have just the return type of
this function so let's say we have our
add return and then we can use a utility
type which typescript itself provides as
well called return type
and this is a generic type so we can
pass it in that we have to pass it in
the type of a function so what we do
type of
this ad here
and what this now does here is
it returns this number because this is
the return type if I change this to
string then it returns as the string so
but how does typescript do this well
let's create this return type ourselves
my return type
and then let's say we pass it in a t we
don't care what it is and then we say
well if T extends a function type
basically if this is a function with any
arguments and which returns anything
then for the start just return any
otherwise return never because we're not
interested in it so but now if we change
this to my return type
it's got much worse because we just got
back any we don't get the real type back
why because of course typescript doesn't
magically know what we want to get
returned from this from this function so
how can we fix this we can use the infer
keyword we can say well typescript if
this T extends a function type then
please take the element at this position
here
and save it in the in a variable let's
call it just R for return type and then
please return it
and as you can see now now we get the
number back so
we can change this again to string it
will get us the string back so this is
how we can use the infer type to get
certain elements of your types and out
and create new types from it you can
call it like Advanced map types
basically
so but how can you use this in in other
in other areas so let's say you want to
do recursion so we are here just on my
local machine not in in AWS or
serverless so it can't get expensive
really fast so let's say we have a type
here and let's say we want to return
promise
and we have a promise inside a promise
inside a promise and there let's say
there is gold in there
and we want to have the gold so the
problem is of course this is wrapped in
many layers of promises so but
typescript knows that this is a this is
a problem that happens really often so
how can we fix this well we can use the
awaited keyword of typescript what it
does is it goes recursively through the
through the promises and as soon as it
finds something which isn't a promise it
just Returns the the type it found so
let's do this ourselves let's do this
with arrays let's say we have an
unwrapped array here we pass it in any
type we want and we say well if as long
as this type is an array so basically as
long as this T extends array please give
me this inner type so this generic type
of this array and just call this unwrap
array again because we want to do this
as long as we don't find an array type
so we say if this extends array we just
call unwrap array again with this inner
type
otherwise we return just the type
because as soon as he as we don't find
anything which is an array we return the
type
so let's say we have our unwrapped array
here
and we have an array array array
and there is called again and then we
want to like unwrap this of course if we
check this array as we can see this like
nested array
so but if we use unwrap array on it
as you can see now we get the type back
because we go recursively through our
our type hierarchy and take the first
element we found interesting so this is
like the simple
part of recursion because we don't want
like to build an object or like build a
type ourselves so let's do it let's do a
little bit more complex stuff let's say
we have an RGB Tuple here and we say
here we have this pupil is a num a
number two pull with three elements
so for all the ones who haven't used me
with with tuples it's just like a fixed
length array so if I say I have a heaven
an object here which I say this is of
type RGB Tuple and I say this is one one
one this compiles fine if I remove
something then this will throw one error
here because
um there are not three elements in it so
just a quick side note if you use things
like these the problem is in typescript
you can always just use push or pop on
it even if it's a fixed length array so
you can still change the amount of
filaments in there so to fix this just
add read only to it
and now push or pop is no longer
available just a quick side note so
now it's it's cool we have done this
we've done this manually with three
elements but let's say you are working
with like Legacy software or something
like this and let's just say you have
like something which gives you back an
array with 54 elements in it and you
want to type this so let's say you could
write all the numbers yourself in there
but it's quite repetitive and you have
to check how many you have really in
there and so on so wouldn't it be cool
if typescript could do this for us if
typescript could say well I have a tupu
I want three elements and I want to only
allow numbers in it so how could we do
this well typescript sadly doesn't
support this but we can do this
ourselves so how would we do this in a
normal a normal pseudocode or in
JavaScript or in any other language we
would create like an empty array and
then loop as long over an index as long
as this the length of the array hasn't
met the length of the which we put in
which we want the array to have this is
exactly what we can do in in these types
we can say we have our Tuple type here
the first element is the length we want
it to have so it has to be a number the
second element is the type of the Tuple
so here it's just the numbers we want to
have in there and the third one is like
an accumulator like an array where we
store all our types
so we say this has to extend Tuple type
array
so because this way we tell typescript
you can only store elements only types
of this type in there so we can then now
close it and we can say well to start
with just return any Now typescript
isn't satisfied here because it says
well you have to pass in this empty
array to start with well we can fix this
and we can say no if we don't pass in
anything just add an empty array so just
start off with an empty array so
what we now could do
what we now could do is we could say
instead of returning any we first say
what's what is our breakout condition so
we say well our accumulator here if the
length
of this array
is the length we have here of of the the
length we passed in if this is the same
just return every return the accumulated
value otherwise if it hasn't reached
this length we will just call it again
so we will go in there let's put this on
new lines and we will go and call Tuple
again and we just will
call it with the length and with the
Tuple type and now we need to add an
element to our to our fixed length array
so how do we do this like you would do
in any immutable language we create a
new array spread our existing elements
into it
and add a tuple type to it
and that's already it so we can now see
what has this done this is now exactly
the same as before with three elements
and I now can but go and say well I want
to change this to 10.
and this will now create a tuple type
with 10 elements you can also say you
want like on not just straight numbers
on but only strings so if you say I want
here an element with a one which is a
string I can then say Okay I want one
with three elements and I want a number
or a string and now this works again so
you have like a generic type which you
can use to create your own tuples or
anything you'd like and you can also say
this as far as 999 because at a thousand
typescript says well that's enough we
don't want you to do this anymore
because they have like a hard stop for
recursion at 999 recursions and prior it
was around 40 so they put the number up
quite a bit but I think you hardly even
need to use this
all right so this is how you can use
like
recursion to build your own types so
before I end this this recursion I'd
like to ask um How am from the one of
you who have worked with angular how
many of you have worked with reactive
forms prior to where they were typed
how many of you okay just some of you
okay so
for the other ones I think it's also
interesting even if you did not have the
the pleasure to work with this before
they were typed so let's say you have
you have a form you have like your form
in your in your application
and this is an example form and let's
say you have a first name which is a
string
and a last name which is string and now
you have like a nested object like you
have a street in there which has a
street name
name which is a string and you have also
Street number which is a string now you
could create this in typescript and then
connect this to your HTML and if you'd
like if you wanted to access like a form
control like for example this street
name here then you could do the
following you could say you have your
let's call this street name control and
then you could access this form group
you've created and then you could say
well I have I use get and I then have
like a string array where I can say well
I want the address
and in there I want the street
and in there I want the street name
now the problem with this of course was
that this was not typed at all so if I
changed anything here in my street if I
change this to Street one then there
would no be no compile time error but
only a runtime error so it could be that
sometimes later in your running code you
get an error like I can't find this form
control because you did not get the
result
um at compile time so we had to fix this
so what I did was I created like a type
for it so
and this type look like this so let's
say we have a type here path and we pass
it in a t and what this now for example
would give back if we pass it in form
example form it should give it should
have given us back all the possible
paths through our through our object so
for example it should give us back first
name and then last name and then also
address
but also address and Street and so on so
every possible allowed path that we only
get the value paths so how do did we do
this well this is now maybe a little bit
more complicated because even of um
especially after lunch where everyone is
a little bit relaxing so but the all the
code is on my GitHub which I will show
you at the end of the talk so you can go
there tomorrow or in a week or never if
you don't like it and then just check it
out so let's pass it in our tea and what
do we really want to do here like we
want to iterate
um recursively over our property keys
and if we find an object we want to go
deeper into it and then just like build
our our our array which um which way and
then we have like a path which looks
like a path so how do we do this well we
say if T extends object
in this case we are interested in it
otherwise we are not interested in it
and in this case we create like a mapped
type we just Loop
over
our key
we say has to be in key of T basically
this is just means that we Loop over the
key in our current object and now for
the value we say well we want to allow
the key so basically let's say we are at
this at this address here we say the key
now is the address so we put the address
as an as the only element in this
allowed in this in this fixed length
array in this two pool and then we but
we also what we also want to do we want
to like dive deeper into our object and
go recursively into it and we can then
say yeah well we want to allow this key
key being the address but also
everything we found later so we then can
just call Path again
and what do we have to pass into into
our recursive call well if we are here
at this address we basically want to
Loop through this object so we can just
say well if T is our address we can say
well I want to like
access the object at this position so we
say t
and of K so we like dive go one
recursion recursive call deeper into it
and now typescript isn't really
satisfied because it tells us well yeah
rest type must be an array but let's
just not think about this let's just say
we have the type and let's check what
this type does
we have our path and we have our example
form
and what does this really return to us
as you can see this returns an object
still with the key being a first the
first name of the value then being like
this array with one element and then
here at address something strange
happens because we have this address
here and then this address with this any
here which isn't really what we want
and now we do some really black magic
and
we can now say we are really not
interested in the keys we want to use
only the values and after we've done
everything like we recursively called
everything we can now flatten out
everything we've created in our in our
values by using key off
tea
and now
we got every possible path in our in our
object returned as a union type so what
this now brings us what this now gives
to us is we can just re comment this out
and remove the comment and then we can
say well
this is a path from an example form
and
if I now for example change here the
street to one then this no longer
compiles because typescript tells me
well this form you have here doesn't
have a path which has this street in it
so if you now have for example a huge
form and you change one or two and parts
of it then we'll see in your code first
where you really use it and second if
this really if the if the path is still
working at compile time so you do not
have to to worry about and do like full
text search and things like this anymore
all right so that's how recursions
recursion can can be done and the next
thing I'd also wanted to show you is
branded types and for me this that's why
I put it at the end of my talk I really
find this extremely powerful also used
in in any project even if it's really
small so let's say we have an email here
and this email is let's call him
type dot rocks so
um let's say you want to send an email
and you use a function here send email
you have an input here and now the
problem is this input here is just a
string because you don't want to pass
around like a wrapped object because for
example in domain driven design or in in
many books there is like yeah you can
like create like these these these
simple these simple objects which for
example are then called email address
and you know everywhere that this is an
email address but often you then have to
like unwrap this object to work with it
so it has three types we could do is
much easier so let's say how can we fix
this send email that we can't pass it
anything we'd like well we can have like
a function and let's call this is email
valid and in there we have like a string
and
then what we do is we return a Boolean
if of course if this is valid or not now
I could go to stack Overflow or ask chat
GPT for like awesome regex for for email
but it will also just catch around 90 of
of the stuff so I will do a much much
better thing I will say and this is much
better I say includes and then I add an
at sign here and then I'm satisfied so
this will work for you put this in
production we don't have an error so as
you can now can see we say if is email
valid we have this email and then we say
send email email
well the problem is this hasn't given us
anything because of course you can just
call the send email address and send
email wherever you want because you
don't have to wrap this so how can we
fix this well start easy and let's say
we have a valid email type here and
let's say this is just an alias for a
string nothing more currently so where
do we really only want valid emails so
we want it here
and now this is email valid function
should not return a Boolean but what it
should return instead is a type card
what is a type card type card is simply
we tell typescript listen this is not
only
a string but we can then say well this
input is valid email
so we can like narrow the type down but
now as you can see everything still
compiles so it's not has not really
given us anything because typescript
knows yeah well valid email is just an
80s for a string so there is there's
nothing nothing to do with this type
card so and now the the magic happens
and we can say well this is not just a
string this is also
has also a property in it and let's call
this property brand you can call this
anything you'd like it's not really
important I just call this brand so that
I know well
um this is some something I shouldn't
shouldn't touch because it's from
typescript and then I say well the value
here let's call this a valid email you
can call this anything you'd like and
now as you can see something interesting
happened line 18 doesn't compile anymore
everything else still compiles and even
if I would say well okay I say this
email here is a valid email this also
does not compile because typescript
tells you well this is just a string
it's missing this brand property here so
but why is it working in here in this in
this in this if Branch because we told
typescript listen this is not just the
string because we are checking here for
a string but it could be like if you
have an object and you have a b and c in
it if you check if you want to only if
you have an input width which where you
only check for a being present that
could be also that B and C is also in
there we all just checking for if this
if a string is in there and now we can
say well this input is not only a string
in this case but also like has this
brand and so in there it works like
before and in there we can even say for
example valid email
which is a valid email here and then we
can assign email to it we don't have to
do it just to show you that it's
possible but as soon as we put this
outside this branch
this will no longer compile
I have to check
valid email oh I think there is a type
yeah
but I think this should no longer oh
sorry that I only checked the first yeah
I have never seen this before so okay
and so the problem here is of course as
you can see
um this knot doesn't compile because
um there is missing this additional
brand this additional brand property so
but how is this really helpful so this
way you can like also work with your
primitive types and make sure that
everywhere you use this valid email type
it's really just a valid email so you
for you don't have to wrap it like in
like an object with one with one
property or something like this you can
work with your strings or also with
numbers you could work with any
primitive types so you could also change
this for example to number and only
allow like positive numbers in there so
to make sure that for example you can
only pass in something which is negative
you can just create like your own
branded types for it so
to end this you could of course just do
this yourself and each and every time
but what you also could do is you could
create like yourself a small utility
function to create these brand of types
for you
so before I end my talk I will try to do
this so we just return we change this
back to Boolean and we leave this all as
it is we'll remove this type valid email
and now let's create a function we have
a function let's call this function
brand
and this brand function takes some
generic arguments the first one is a
primitive type this is like a string or
a number or a Boolean or something like
this the second one is like the brand
name it's like the string this valid
email we had and the third one is like
uh it's like something which gets
created from the first two like this
brand which we then can say well we
extend
A Primitive type and
we have
the brand here with brand name
all right
I will put this on two lines
three lines even so
and now what we can do is
in your in our inputs what do we want to
put into our inputs well we want to put
put in like this email valid function so
this function we we just want to use to
check if this is like the type card
function so let's call this is type
function and we pass it in our input
which is of type primitive in primitive
type and of course this returns a
Boolean like this is email valid
function and the second argument is just
the brand name
with the type brand name now what do we
return I really like from react like
this this where we use the hooks this
this destructuring of this of the arrays
where you have like your your two
elements in it so let's do this let's do
the same and let's say the first element
we return is like this this type card
function this primitive is primitive
type here and it returns input is brand
and the second element we return is just
the brand itself so that we know which
type we can work with now in our
implementation and the five part is the
implementation is smaller than the the
function interface so we have our Ace
brand here and we say this is just a
function which takes as an input our
primitive type but it returns of course
input is
a brand
now we just call this is type function
we we pass in this is email valid here
we use and we pass it in this email
and now we return it we say is brand
gets returned and the second one we just
pass it an empty object and say as brand
why do we do this I will show you right
away so we have now this param function
and now how can we really use this
we can say we have a const here and
let's call this the first element is is
email the second one is valid email
object
and then we can say well we call our
brand
and in there what we can do is we say we
pass it our easy email valid function
and our valid email
app string now the important part is
that this is email here as you can see
now the brand is valid email if I remove
this as const
this brand here
is just a string why because if you
don't use as cons typescript says well
this is just a string it maybe it can
maybe change so we will like not narrow
it down to the actual string so we have
to use as cons
so and now what you can do here instead
is we can say we have to type valid
email and we can say type of valid email
object
and as you can see now everything
um works again I have to just check here
why this doesn't work
brand string
brand valid email oh I have to check
here
this brand extends
funny
oh yeah that's I I have when I when I
did when I did my my try I had exactly
the same error at exactly the center
technical scatters because this will not
happen again no of course not okay so
now as you can see this works and but
now we don't haven't really much more
much more stuff but what we now can do
is let's just remove everything here
and what we now could do is we can say
is positive number
and we say positive
number object and we then have here and
we say well
in what is our check function for a
positive number we say well the input is
a number and well the input has to be
greater than
zero and then we can say here positive
number and now we can have like create
our own branded type and we can just use
it we can say we have a number here
here which is one and we can say if
is positive number we can pass it in our
number and now in here we can be sure
that this has to be a positive number so
we have positive here which is a
positive number
and not a position but the positive
number and this now would work here if I
just had created the type here
positive number
is type of positive number object and as
you can see this compiles but as soon as
I move this outside
this will no longer compile because you
don't have the safety so this I will I
use always in my projects to be sure
that I can pass around strings but can
still be sure that this status the data
string still comply to the patterns I'd
like them to have and the cool thing
also is of course because this is just a
normal primitive you can still access
all its properties or its functions you
can work with it like a normal string
so
that's already it for my talk what I
wanted to show you before I end my talk
is how you could really bring it to
another level so you could do something
like this
and you could create like a validator
like a validator if it's if a string you
pass into a function is a valid
mathematical equation so for example
here this will this at the top always
does compile because this is a valid a
valid equation if I for example remove
this three here I get an error because
this is not valid and can't be can be um
create an equation from it so but as you
can see here is a missing closing
bracket mismatched brackets and all
everything it's also my GitHub you can
check it out and it's yeah it's around
40 lines of code it's a little bit crazy
but if you get into it I think it's it's
not necessarily crazy at all
so
yeah
yeah that was my talk I'd really really
wanted to uh think that you took the
time out of your day and also after
lunch you you came here and sat down
here and listened to me and yeah and if
you'd like to ask me anything or so
please write me and or link me on
LinkedIn or write me an email I'd really
like to hear from you and yeah I want to
thank you for being here and wish you an
awesome NDC conference and yeah thank
you
foreign